[Music]
thus what in religion was content or
reform for presenting and other is hear
the self's own act the notion requires
the content to be the self's own act for
this notion is as we see the knowledge
of the cells act within itself as all
essentiality and all existence the
knowledge of this subject is substance
and of the substance as this knowledge
of its Act
our own act here has been simply to
gather together the separate moments
Each of which in principle exhibits the
life of spirit in its entirety and also
to stick to the notion in the form of
the notion the content of which would
already have yielded itself in those
moments and in the form of a shape of
consciousness
paragraph 797 is quite important it is
the first of four short paragraphs that
are carrying out an incredibly important
set of pivots or transitions from where
we've been in the absolute knowing
section heading into some speculations
or rather consolidations ultimately
about time and history and the nature of
absolute knowing and the Consciousness
there's so much that we could say here I
could go on and on and on and 797 and
798 go together in part because they're
both talking about you know the
transition point between them this shape
of Consciousness a Gestalt right and
this is a term that we've been using
throughout the phenomenology
maybe we'll pause on that and talk a
little bit about what a shape of
consciousness really is in the next
paragraph commentary I do want to point
a few things out about the Miller
translation you know usually I'm pretty
easy on Miller in part because I've been
a translator myself not so much from
German but more from French and Latin
and from Greek I've done some German
translation as well in my time and and I
know how difficult it can be to find
exactly the right word or the best
phrasing for something and you know I'll
point out here and there oh you know
Miller's making a choice here or he's
adding something this is a paragraph
where without tearing Miller down I want
to say wow there's a greater
concentration of
questionable choices on the translators
part in this little paragraph by
comparison to to many others
so you know one that I'm going to bring
up is this important like
repetition of our own act right because
he's talking so much in the first couple
sentences about the self's own act The
Agonist one does zelps and we see him
using this same phrase so we would
imagine that you know we were
elaborating it in the abstract and then
we talk about our own action and there
isn't any of that language actually in
there it's it's Vos vir here
right so what we hear in this place at
this time in this transition
um did you know uh in this or back then
and so it's not I mean it it is our own
act true right but we should understand
this more as a gloss on Miller's part
than what Hegel himself is actually
saying here there's another thing where
you know in German uh and Hegel actually
just did this in the previous paragraphs
partly partly tiles tiles right and in
in the second part uh when he says our
own act here has simply been simply to
gather together the separate moments
it's actually tiles uh di for zamlung
right and we'll talk about that in just
a moment
so it's not simply because it's actually
doing two different things
Hartley Gathering Together partly
sticking to so the phrasing there is a
little bit uh misleading for a
german-less reader we should also point
out that in that section
Miller
turns uh
nouns nouns that do signify processes
into active verbs of what it is that we
are doing right so D for zamlong
um you know for zamolin is is to gather
together right
um but this is the process of gathering
together and then
um sticking to das Fest Halton right
again it is an active
process that's going on but it's not in
the the German so
so clearly a verb as it is there so
there's there's a few things of course
we should point out for this paragraph
and all the succeeding ones we're using
this term notion because Miller uses it
as well but you know more commonly we
translate but grief as concept
notion concept that that's okay either
one is is fine so what is actually
happening here in this paragraph
let's start at the start
what in religion oh here's one more
thing
was content or a form for presenting an
other okay so form for presenting is
form and then the term presenting is
actually
foreshelling right so that should be
either to be consistent with Miller
picture uh thinking or it should just be
representation right it shouldn't just
be presenting in other as a matter of
fact Dar stellen is used a little bit
later in in the second part of this uh
darstell and four Stella not exactly the
same for stellen and for Stallone is
representation right
um darshan is more putting forward
presenting or something like that so
what is religion doing the previous
section what in religion was content in
halt or a form for representation
uh and of an other
so you know we talked about this in the
previous paragraph what is going on in
religion is that we don't we're not
quite finished up with working through
the concept the notion because we still
have a bifurcation the representation is
of an other that we can grasp ourselves
as somehow participating in you know
like through the community the cultists
the narratives all of that sort of stuff
but there's still this alternative there
so what in religion was that here
is
now think about what we've been talking
about in the previous paragraphs these
self's own act now the word here for at
is not the term that we've been using in
the last several paragraphs Honda
although tun has been used at a certain
point here
against
zebs right so the self is acting and
this goes back to the point that we made
in the previous paragraph that you know
for Hegel activity
or action
and actuality right so Honda and vehicle
kite are incredibly important we don't
want to retreat into a mere idealism
that just speculates the world there is
an ongoing activity here and you can say
well you know speculation that is you
know looking upon or thinking about that
that is active right but there's also
this uh very important sense of being a
subject within the world who who acts so
the notion he says and this is very
interesting requires fairbindit s right
it it uh makes it happen to be the case
it requires it imposes upon it on the
content the content that religion has
been dealing with to become to be the
self's own Act
oh what does that mean now the self is
taking charge of it and here we get this
long uh sentence which
there's a lot going on here that we need
to unpack for this notion is as we see
we the phenomenologists looking on right
the phenomenologists who are going to be
moving into this shape of Consciousness
is the knowledge of the self-act within
itself is all essentiality in all
existence the knowledge of this subject
is substance and of the substance as the
knowledge of this act now as I was
thinking about this I
decided that
it might be helpful to actually reverse
the order of some of this within the
sentence so this is all knowledge vicen
which is what this final section is
about absolute you know listen
um but the second two things
so we've got knowledge of what knowledge
of this subject the subject being the
self grasping the content
as substance now he's not going to do
much with that here we are going to see
that in the later paragraphs coming back
and this is you know pretty familiar to
you if you've gone through hegel's
phenomenology self subject substance
these are all you know the the S terms
that we use a lot and then this
substance the knowledge is of the
subject to substance the knowledge is of
this substance meaning this subject
as this knowledge
in its Act
of what act of getting to know things uh
learning understanding engaging with the
substance an active substance a
subjective substance is grasping
knowledge is it the final knowledge it
could be in its act the
own act The Agonist twin the proper act
would be another way of thinking about
this and so then after we think about it
in those terms and pause on that for a
moment we can say that this knowledge is
also as he's going to say right here
right the knowledge of the self's own
Act
within itself
uh Des Tunes
in Zeke and notice that the the German
you know is a little bit reversing this
the knowledge is of deaths right the the
sort of uh the genitive here in German
right we would say the possessive in
English uh of the act of the self
in itself and then the in Zeke there
um is sort of an intensifier right it's
in a way saying the real uh action the
actual act if we want to be a little bit
facetious but the enzig could apply both
to the the ACT
the twin right the act in itself and to
the self in itself reflexive
intensifying the self makes perfect
sense from a hegelian perspective and
then we go on as what
now notice the two sides of this
as all essentiality Alice right so it's
not just as essentiality but as all
essentiality and it's not as Essence
it's uh which would be vase and it's vs
and height right the essentiality and
all existence
now does this mean that the self really
becomes all existence no no no but the
self is grasping itself at the center of
existence oriented towards something
that is essentiality right so all of
this is going on with this unpacking of
what it is that the notion requires the
content uh to be namely the self's own
Act
then we get this transition
what is our own act or literally what it
is that we did here
um in this
so it's leading us to a shape of
Consciousness
right and you know we've got lots of
shapes of Consciousness along the way
that's cool uh maybe it's a shape of
Consciousness we've already encountered
in the religion section or perhaps uh as
hegel's been stressing in the spirit
section or maybe it's a new Shape Of
Consciousness we'll have to see when we
get to the next paragraph right but what
is our own act doing so this is where
the tiles comes up the partly in part
this in part that so it's gathering
together that's one thing that it's
doing what is it Gathering Together the
separate
or you know we could also translate this
as individual
moments the separate moments and what
else does Hegel tell us about this
Gathering Each of which in principle
exhibits the life Laban
of spirit in its entirety
okay so what are we talking about there
we're talking about
moments that themselves are not just
moments of a particular Gestalt we're
talking about entire gestalten right
entire shapes of Consciousness that we
have gone through previously and then it
does something else alongside this which
is to stick to that's Fest Halton
it clings to right uh the notion in the
form of the notion the notion as it is
being developed the notion as such we
could say the the truly conceptual
concept
um and what does he tell us about that
the content of which would already have
yielded itself in those moments in those
separate moments
the content
the content but not yet completely the
form because that's going to lead us to
the shape
of Consciousness right in the form of a
shape of Consciousness so again we have
to ask ourselves okay good is it a shape
we already know is it a shape we've run
into before
or is this something new that's being
contributed and that's where we get
ready to move into the next paragraph
this last shape of spirit the spirit
which at the same time gives its
complete and true content the form of
the self and thereby realizes its notion
is remaining in its notion in this
realization this is absolute knowing it
is spirit that knows itself in the shape
of spirit or a comprehensive knowing in
terms of the notion
truth is not only in itself completely
identical with certainty but it also has
the shape of self-certainty or it is in
its existence in the form of
self-knowledge Truth is the content
which in religion is still not identical
with its certainty
but this identity is now a fact in that
the content has received the ver the
shape of the self as a result that which
is the very essence that is the notion
has become the element of existence
or has become the form of objectivity
for Consciousness spirit
manifesting or appearing in
Consciousness in this element or what is
the same thing produced in it by
consciousness
is science
we start paragraph
798 answering the question that was
raised for us at the end of the previous
paragraph namely what is this shape of
spirit that we're looking at a shape of
Consciousness and it turns out it's the
last shape of spirit absolute knowing so
this final section is itself
constituting a new Gestalt of
Consciousness and as we're going to see
at the end of this paragraph he's going
to bring in another term which we saw
discussed quite a bit in the preface
namely science right Vision shaft and
there's a important transition going on
here is what what actually constitutes
that we're not going to get too deep
into that but
we should think about what a Gestalt is
and this is a very very interesting
paragraph in that shape
which we typically see being used for
Shape Of Consciousness right
it's being used for shape of spirit
shape of the self
shape of
self-certainty right it's uh being
transformed or rather it's a term that's
being extended into all sorts of
possible applications so he tells us
this last shape of spirit is absolute
knowing okay so what is this last shape
of spirit then he tells us that the
spirit gives its complete and true
content now complete there
brought to fruition right it's not just
complete as in like ticking off a bunch
of boxes it's fully developed and it's
also true and we're going to see truth
talked about quite a bit here and we
should remember that in Hegel
um truth and certainty there's been this
dialectic going back and between them
you begin with certainty and then you
start thinking about what you're certain
of and you find out that oh it's not
completely true so you try to get to the
true and in the process you lose some of
the certainty which is good because
that's being scientific being hedging
your bats qualifying and then you want
to bring the two of them together it's
you know the typical hegelian Shuffle
right so it it gives complete or true
content in halts we've just been talking
a lot about uh content the form
of the self
what is the form of the self well
the self is something Dynamic the self
is something that can bring negativity
within its own confines and has to do so
by virtue of being a self a self if we
want to play off of a word that we're
going to unpack here in just a little
bit a self is not a pure Timeless
identity
it doesn't remain exactly the same all
the time
he goes on in this and he says that uh
it thereby by giving this complete and
true content the form of the self
realizes its notion that the begriff
right as remaining in its notion in this
realization now the German is a little
bit closer to this as it remains in this
realization and thereby in this notion
right so I think the translation implies
that by remaining in the notion it
remains in the realization when it's
actually
lexically the opposite and I do want to
point out here
that Hegel
doesn't use anything like you know
vehicle leak or vehicle kite which we
often do translate as reality or you
know uh actuality or realization he's
actually using the Latin term
realizerin right and
um it's being used as a verb and then as
a noun that's composed of that verb and
we could say
produces just as much as makes real
right
producing is making something real
making something that was
merely possible or conceived of into
something that we can actually
see so it's not totally disengaged from
actuality or reality right so it it
produces it realizes it unpacks it makes
complete this notion as it remains
bliped as it as it stays
in this realization so there's something
important about if you want to have the
notion or the concept you gotta you know
if we go back to the preface you have to
Terry with the negative you have to
linger with the things that we do
encounter you can't just Retreat into
idealistic la la land and make it all up
as you go along you got to work with the
stuff that you got
now he goes on in this and he tells us
that
it is spirit that knows itself in and
again we encounter Gestalt in the shape
of spirit right so the last shape of
spirit in absolute knowing Spirit knows
itself in the proper shape of spirit
which has been working towards this
entire time
um and here we again it would be nice if
we used concept rather than uh notion
because what he's talking about here is
a knowing a vision that is comprehensive
or conceptual big hyphen Doh you know it
it wraps itself around the object of its
knowledge it knows itself in knowing the
object of its knowledge again that's
part of what vissen shocked or science
in its full sense is going to mean we've
got to be careful too when we read the
word science not to imagine that in
German it means exactly the same thing
that we call science which is a little
bit more restrictive right we don't
typically think of philosophy or history
as science is but they are in fact
science is in this this conception and
part of what makes something more
scientific is that it is comprehensive
right so spirit is knowing itself
comprehensively
conceptually not just by means of
representation
or the you know hey we'll call it later
and the lectures on the philosophy of
religion the
um understanding way but it's it's
grasping it through reason
so we go on here and now he starts
talking about truth and he says a lot of
things about truth or variety
truth is not only in itself completely
identical with certainty right and
certainly here give his height
um now completely identical with
bit of a mistranslation there the
completely is not a
superlative uh you know it's actually
full culminant right and this is the
complete here full Coleman so brought to
its fruition fully developed right but
identical so identical here
Hagel is using a term
that we have to be a little bit careful
he's using the term glyc which is a
adjective here and then he's going to
talk about like height which gets
translated as identity like can in fact
mean equal to
but it doesn't necessarily imply being
exactly the same thing
so
equality
equivalence
congruence right there's a lot of ways
we could uh render this so truth
isn't identical as in being entirely
substitutable for or being exactly the
same thing as certainty but it's finally
been harmonized you could say with
certainty which is what we've been
looking for this whole entire process of
the phenomenology
so
he goes on and he says it also has the
shape
again Gestalt of
self-certainty now uh is this
self-certainty as in zelps give his
height no it's good
this might seem to be quibbling a little
bit right but it might be translated
better as certainty of its very own
self and you can say well how's that
different than self-certainty well
there's a more intensive reflexive uh
thing being signaled here by the the
very language certainty of its very own
self
truth is this which means
truth so yeah let's let's have a little
bit of a digression right uh sometimes
we talk and intro to philosophy classes
about like you know different theories
of Truth and we say you know Hegel is
not a big fan of the correspondence
theory of Truth which is partly true
um and he's not you know a pragmatist
he's he's very much about a different
kind of Truth which has to do with the
totality and everything holding together
which we call often the coherence theory
of Truth Hegel doesn't use that language
this is coming much later on right
um now what this implies though here is
that truth is not just something which
the subject sits back and then notes in
the entire hole this is very important
for what absolute knowing is and this
goes back to the comprehensive the geith
and uh knowing right
it is not just you as the subject
grasping the totality and seeing that
there's no real
incoherencies or contradictions left
between the different elements or
however we want to frame it the moments
the
propositions
you are in there as truth
right so this is not just a con uh
coherence theory of Truth where the uh
truth graspers sits back and just gets
the totality you are part of that
totality
so what's going on here is is different
it's a it's a richer
uh concept if we want to use that term
but I think it would be perfectly
appropriate of truth that is at play
here where the truth itself is
consciousness right anyway it is the
shape of self-certainty and then he goes
on and says something else that is quite
interesting
um
right uh
it it has the shape of self-certainty or
it has its existence it is in its
existence in the form of self-knowledge
now Hegel doesn't say it quite like that
he says that it is in its existence it's
dazine right truth is in its own
existence and then he says Das Heist
that means
that now here's closer to the German
it is for knowing Spirit Vista Geist in
the form of
knowing itself
right so in its existence that is
in for knowing spirit in the form of
knowing itself these are also things
that are
not identical but are the same you know
meaning or we can unpack it you could
say right so it's not just in its
existence in the form of self-knowledge
it's a little bit more complex here so
we're getting a very interesting
discussion of Truth as it pertains to
Absolute knowing and then he goes on and
he says truth is the content which in
religion is still not identical it's
unlike right with its certainty but this
identity is now a fact the word fact is
not in there in the German at all right
there's nothing that actually
corresponds that I'm not sure why Miller
wants to say that unless we understand
fact in the older sense not of just
being something that we observe but
something that is produced a factum
right something that was done
in that the content has received the
shape of the cell so now we've got shape
of spirit shape Consciousness shape of
self-certainty and shape of self right
and he'll talk about the shape of the
self and the essence the vasen of the
self and what is this
he goes on
that which is the very essence
the notion
the essence of the self the notion has
become two things
the element of existence dazine which
we've seen talked about here right so
something that actually exists
but also
the form of objectivity
right now not objectivity in the sense
of sometimes English speakers say oh
something is objective as opposed to
subjective it's the damn self we're
talking about here of course it's
subjective right it's a subject
um so don't think of objectivity in that
sense but objectivity is something that
is out there that we can encounter
ourselves
are in part outside of our self
aren't they
and
what does this exist for well
it says the notion has become the
element of existence or has become the
form of objectivity for
consciousness
and then he says Spirit manifesting or
appearing in Consciousness in this
element the element being existence
right or what is the same thing produced
in it by consciousness
this is science this is vicenshaft this
is what we've been seeking for the
entire time now of course we've been
seeking other things to recognition you
know honor Canon uh the other
self-consciousness but we've also been
looking for I want to figure out what
the hell's going on here and where I fit
in and how I relate to the rest of the
stuff that I can know will about think
about desire right and that's what
science is getting us to so we now have
a explicit
sketch of what the last Shape Of
Consciousness the last shape of spirit
the last shape of the self is
absolute knowing the section that we are
now deep within and figuring out what is
absolute knowing actually mean well one
answer is it is science in the full
sense